for eight years during Barack Obama's
time in office his predecessor George W
Bush was really quiet well he painted a
lot
remember this one he did of the dogs
what they look like goats well and W
gave speeches and he wrote an
autobiography he did a lot of great
charity appearances for the military but
he refused to utter even the Thema STUV
criticism as Obama was taking a wrecking
ball to America's domestic and foreign
policy I think about it when the Obama
administration upended our health care
system Bush said nothing when Obama ran
through bloated stimulus bills and
exploded our debt Bush was mom when
horror stories of neglect at the VA
surfaced total silence when the Obama
administration abandoned our men and
Benghazi and then sent Susan Rice out to
lie about the attack well the cat had
w's tongue and when Obama threatened
religious liberty with his contraception
mandate crickets when he was asked to
comment about Obama policies this was
Bush's customary response I don't think
it's good for the country to have a
former president undermine a current
president I think it's bad for the
presidency for that matter but since
Trump was elected George W Bush seems
willing and eager to spout off although
he doesn't mention Trump by name he
might as well and not only is he
criticizing our 45th president he's now
doing so on foreign soil that's nice
today in Dubai where else he criticized
Trump for ending the daka policy
claiming there are people willing to do
jobs that Americans won't do Americans
don't want to pick cotton 105° but there
are people who want to put food on their
family's tables and are willing to do
that we ought to say say thank you and
welcome them okay
not Will Ferrel but give me a break now
Hillary Clinton couldn't have said it
better herself Bush tried this routine
back in 2007 his amnesty with a side of
border security it didn't work then and
it certainly is not going to work in the
era of Trump but Bush didn't stop a
needling Trump about immigration he also
offered this trenchant insight on
Russia's election interference the
elections foreign nation that recorded
on an old Barbie tape recorder what's
that look if I were George W Bush I
wouldn't be so quick to bring up Russian
meddling I kind of recall memory he was
at the ranch and Crawford
he was pretty cozy with Putin when he
came to the visit Texas remember he
looked into Vlad's eyes and I think he
saw his soul as I recall so it was okay
to try to work with Russia back then but
not now right well I say this about
looking into Putin's soul I didn't Bush
so badly misjudged Vladimir's
let's face it Bush is repulsed by Donald
Trump because number one the bushes are
globalists Trump's more of an economic
nationalist number two
Trump selection was a repudiation of
both the bushes and the Clintons and
also of course W is still smarting from
Trump's trouncing his baby brother Jeb
and the primaries poor chaplains doing
another commercial on me this guy
he's a maniac this poor guy I feel sorry
it's like a lost soul you know this poor
pathetic low-energy guy and my friend
are you talking Jim I'm talking right
now I'm talking you can go back
you're not talking you interrupted
September 30 you can apologize Jeff no a
little bit ya know you're trying to
build up your anyways yeah but it's not
working oh my god that was so funny so
it's to be expected
come on that was brutal that the bushes
would return to their natural habitat
after all these years places where no
one questions international trade deals
or the massive flood of humanity into
our country but it's painfully obvious
that the bushes were never comfortable
with conservatives of the Reagan
Buchanan Gingrich or certainly not the
Trump variety they are comfortable
however cozying up to the Obamas or
hanging out with the Clintons I don't
that make any sense but President Bush
told me use some big words
so President Bush this is the point
where I reach in my back pocket to make
sure my billfold still there
I don't know any big words that's sweet
well that nice it brings back such great
memories
oh okay let's get back to the
proposition we put out at the beginning
of the show why is your chubby bush
suddenly so vocal yeah we're going to
talk about successive presidents well I
think it might have something to do with
the economy taking off of course the
current market correction not books
notwithstanding 70% of registered voters
in a new Quinnipiac poll say the economy
is excellent or good under Trump that
same poll found that Trump's approval
ratings are up to 40% in an economist
YouGov survey has met 45 and then you
throw in the incredible State of the
Union the unraveling of this ridiculous
Russian investigation we're gonna get
into more of that with Dershowitz and
Starr and the elites like the Bush's
probably feel that now they need to
respond the stuff Trump's doing is
actually working the president should
wear the tired Bush critiques as a badge
of honor Trump is doing what previous
administrations were unwilling or unable
to do and President Bush himself should
know by now come on there's no
constituency for perpetual military
intervention open borders and totally
uninterested --nt george w bush your
brother ran on that platform and the
people chose Trump and that's the angle